two men are dead after an argument over
the sale of an AR-15 rifle Metro Police
say occurred just before 5 30 at the
Rubik's Apartments that's near Craig and
Las Vegas Boulevard by Nellis Air Force
Base Madison Kimbrough has the details
Patrol responded they went up to the
apartment
they came into contact with a person
reporting and they observed two
individuals lying on the floor of the
apartment suffering from gunshot wounds
two men are dead after what police say
was an argument over buying a gun the
two individuals came to the apartment to
purchase a firearm
during the negotiations of that firearm
they decided they did not want to
purchase it they just wanted to take it
without the without paying for it that's
when Metro officers say a struggle
ensued and shots were fired when Medics
arrived they declared one man dead at
the scene the other was taken to UMC and
died shortly after neighbors who live at
the Rubik's Apartments where the
shooting occurred near Craig and Las
Vegas Boulevard so the area is mostly
quiet but there have been some issues of
people getting into disagreements nearby
two lives are gone that'll never be back
because of the neighborhood that this is
in and stuff like this here I kind of I
kind of think it probably had something
to do with disrespect police confirming
that everyone involved is accounted for
and stating that this is an isolated
incident
it is unclear if the weapon involved was
legally owned but police say it was an
AR-15 Metro also would not confirm if
any arrests have been made